all right uh let's talk briefly about
the coming wild card round and we've got
all week to talk about it but just
for now we we we know the six games
which one
of the six are you looking forward to
the motion
well mike i'm looking forward to the
titans and the ravens meeting again just
because they met twice obviously
recently at the end of last season in
the postseason that was a huge titans
upset
28-12 we all thought the ravens were
going to go to the super bowl and going
to be
super bowl champions and it didn't work
out that way and
and derek henry destroyed him 195 yards
and even threw a touchdown pass in that
one and then they come back this year
and the titans win again
with derek henry having that overtime
touchdown run i think it was 29 yards
that let him win in overtime so i'm
looking forward to that one and and i
know there's not such a thing as revenge
and there's
you know this is a different team than
last year but
the ravens now are favored despite being
on the road and they get their shot to
get quote-unquote revenge
against the titans and i think this is
going to be a terrific game we may see
almost
well probably over 300 yards rushing
maybe by each team so you could have up
to five or six hundred yards in this
game rushing mike
the ravens have snowed no sign that they
can stop derek henry
and i don't think that titan's defense
can stop anybody on the ravens
the ravens have been great in recent
weeks
the narrative that they can't win in the
playoffs with lamar jackson has gone out
the window because they've been playing
playoff stakes games for the past five
weeks
one false move and they're not in the
dolphins are in
it's it's been proven by the way it
played out they had to win
every one of those games to get to where
they are
so that that i think reduces the
pressure
and the fact that they had that little
skirmish this year in baltimore when
there were guys from the titans who were
out on the logo
before the game and and jim john
harbaugh excuse me got into it with the
players i remember talking
to aj brown after the game he's like a
coach is going to come take on players
are you kidding me
and then mike rabel gets involved and it
was ugly after the game so that adds
some intrigue to it as well
but i i agree with you that to me stands
out
as a must-see game but also the browns
and the steelers 18 years after the only
other playoff game
since the cleveland browns came back
into the league 2002 it was at
pittsburgh same stadium
same circumstance a wild card game
they're at it again
and when the browns went in there
earlier this year
i thought the browns were going to win
because i wasn't impressed with the
steelers wins
that far in the season and the steelers
smacked them down
and we've seen this before where two
teams get together again and the outcome
is different
this past game doesn't matter because it
was jv versus jv between the covet issue
and the steelers resting guys it's going
to be strength on strength
come sunday just like it was back during
the regular season and the steelers
haven't lost to the browns
at heinz field since 2003. i'm
fascinated by that one because i
think if the browns can weather
any early storm then it's going to have
a different vibe
than it did and you throw in the fact
that there isn't going to be a fan in
the building
that game to me is going to be
the most fascinating of the week and it
could be over by the end of the first
quarter
or it could go all the way down to the
wire and the browns could win it and i
have no idea who i'm going to pick in
that one my niece who's a huge browns
fan has already threatened
to disown me if i don't pick the browns
to win that game but
it's going to be tough it's going to be
gutsy to pick the browns based upon what
happened
during the regular season well and
that's what's so weird about this game
mike is normally when we have
back-to-back match-ups like this
like you're like well they they just
played but these are going to be
completely different teams that we're
going to see
this week as compared to last week as
you said it was jv on jv
so that's why to me this game is so
intriguing because these are different
teams than what we saw yesterday
i think the fact that they just lined up
across from those uniforms and helmets
may strip away
some of the intimidation that you would
feel going into pittsburgh
and knowing the last time you went there
you got smacked down
so i i expect the browns to be ready
i expect the browns to be different than
they were earlier this year and let's
face it the steelers are different than
they were earlier this year they've had
one good half of football
the past month and a half can they get
that lawnmower started
and play hard against the browns and
knock them out but that should be a
great we'll be talking about all the
playoff games more as the week unfolds
uh when we return a quick little uh
sliver of last night's conversation on
the football night in america set and
then we'll answer all your questions
coming up after this on pftp
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports